I tell us so far what you know so the
incident actually happened at two hours
in a hospital around 10:30 p.m. local
French time on the on the waterfront on
the promenade des anglais the English
prom night as we call it this is where
people were watching the fireworks you
had about 10,000 people locals and
tourists of course because we're in the
middle of the tourist season of the
holiday season watching the Bastille Day
fireworks and a large truck apparently
the kind of truck that is used to
deliver fresh of frozen products rammed
into the crowd watching the fireworks
obviously the crowd was looking at the
sky as the fireworks and and the truck
apparently drove into the crowds for 700
meters maybe up to two kilometers
killing a dozens of people the prefect
of the region speaking early on french
channel was talking about 30 dead some
other sources are saying the the the
numbers of that might be actually higher
than that and and probably at least 100
injured Carolyn we're also getting
reports from the interior ministry they
say there's no hostage taking going on
at all in Nice right now we know that
president Francois Hollande has traveled
back to Paris amid this remit this
incident so tell me what the response
has been so far from from the government
in Paris so at the moment we know that
the Interior Minister Bernard cazeneuve
was also dealing in the last later
tourist attacks last year and Paris is
traveling to nice as we speak
meanwhile as you were mentioning
president Hollande is traveling back to
Cali to attend the crisis meeting
Fona different authorities are not
picking officially about the terrorist
attack but about a criminal act of
significant importance even though a lot
of ingredients a lot of things that we
can see in the
incident tend to make a thing that this
could be a cherished hotel because we
had seen this kind of situation remember
even before Charlie Hebdo a couple of
years ago during the Christmas period
where you had a couple of terrorist
attacks in France in the east of France
and in the suburbs of Paris where on a
couple of occasions the truck drove into
the crowd so even though the authorities
are not talking officially about a
terrorist attack at the moment they are
looking into whether this driver this
truck driver was the lone wolf was alone
or whether he had some accomplices
Carolyn before we go it's been reported
also that this has been hat this is
happening on the exact day that the
state of emergency emergency has been
lifted in Paris
yeah after those attacks the terrorist
attacks that we saw several months ago
so give us a sense though right now of
the state of security not just in Paris
but of course in the in the Lord in the
country at large yeah in fact on
Bastille Day its traditional president
Ron give this interview on national
television which he did at lunchtime and
this is one year not the end of the
state of emergency that supposed to be
lifted on July 26 so in about ten days
from now he said actually we can't live
in a democracy having a permanent state
of emergency these state of emergency as
you know has been on since the November
13th terrorist attacks so the level of
security was extremely high and this
type of emergency actually allowed the
police authorities to to put some people
under house arrest and to arrest some
people just for to look for itself but
at the moment so as you were mentioning
croissant anon is equal to lift the
state of emergency after this attack
we'll see if he changes his mind on this